[Music]  jennifer aniston stepped out in this  gorgeous one shoulder Brandon Maxwell  jumpsuit on Monday Jan rocked the black  ensemble at the office Christmas party  premiere but it's the designer coat she  wore just before the red carpet that got  our attention it looks like Jennifer  forgot to take the tags off her chic  Celine coat draped over her shoulders  oops still when you're Jennifer Aniston  you can do no wrong except maybe when it  comes to keeping up with hubby Justin  Theroux Jen told ET justin is the life  of the party Jen something tells me  Justin left the party I your guys's  parties that you actually is right he is  the life of them you don't want throw it  without him no no you're dumb people are  very sad when he's not there oh yeah  just really makes me feel Cory  [Music]  and